the high court has ruled that the
government acted unlawfully by awarding
a contract to a company run by friends
of dominic cummings
boris johnson's former chief advisor
campaigners took legal action over the
decision to pay more than 500 000 pounds
of
taxpayers money to the firm our
political correspondent kate mccann
joins us from westminster
and kate obviously pretty difficult for
the government and for dominic cummings
yes it is a difficult decision the
reading of it is interesting though
because the case against the government
suggested that there was an apparent
bias in the decision making not that an
actual bias took place and it's
complicated because of the context where
the decision was made we know
it was the height of the pandemic
everything was very chaotic
inside government ministers were trying
to grapple with something that none of
us had ever gone through before
and they were struggling and it's not
just this contract which of course is
about communications it's about
government messaging and understanding
how people were receiving those messages
it's much broader than that too because
there are now questions being raised
over
ppe contracts and how procurement worked
in general at that time now that's
something that's going to be
investigated further down the line the
prime minister has said he's open to
having that discussion
not quite yet but he is willing to have
it but this particular case hinged on
the idea that actually the government
gave a contract to people who were
friends of as you say dominic cummings
rather than tendering it out to
different companies now ministers say
that that was the right decision at the
time because of
the context as i say there was so much
going on and it was so important to get
those messages out quickly but the court
said that actually
there was an apparent bias and a
right-minded person would have been able
to see that
now angela rainer for the labour party
is saying that there should be an
investigation into whether michael gove
has broken the ministerial code as a
result here's what she had to say this
afternoon
what we need to know is whether the
ministerial code was breached and
actually time and time again
all we're seeing is conservative friends
and associates being awarded contracts
without any tendering process and we're
talking billions of pounds this adds up
to
this is taxpayers money that's been
wasted and it's completely unacceptable
and that's why i think that that money
should be recouped
but equally we need an investigation to
stop this you know this this cronyism
and this you know
a total breach of power it's totally
unacceptable it's not the way we work in
britain you know
good companies are out there that want
to do a good job for us and the
taxpayers deserve every single pound
that they've earned and given
to the treasury should be spent
efficiently and effectively
for the people of this country
now the cabinet office has responded to
angela rayner a spokesman said the
minister was not
involved in the decision to award this
contract questions concerning the
ministerial code therefore do not arise
and there will be no
investigation any suggestion that there
has been a breach of the ministerial
code
is wrong so there will be no personal
implications for michael gove
after this decision today in the high
court but
there will be further investigations and
questions about government procurement
during the time of coronavirus
and about how it can be made more
transparent if anything like this were
ever to happen again
all right kate thank you very much